face à la crise économique et sociale
induite par cette pandémie le secrétaire
général de la cgt philippe martinez dit
souhaiter à un printemps social c'est le
débat de ce soir avec nos deux invités
et nous sommes avec christian de
boissieu vice président du cercle des
économistes benoît martin secrétaire
général cgt paris bonsoir messieurs et
merci d'être avec nous ce soir s'ils
restent sur rt france est-ce qu'on a une
idée christian de boissieu des
destructions d'emplois attendues ces
prochains mois il pourrait se compter
par dizaines de milliers selon philippe
martinez
j'ai pas de chiffres à vous donner j'ai
simplement je pense que le plus dur de
la crise économique et sociale est
devant nous l'api sanitaire est pas
terminée je rappelle ses conséquences
économiques sont pour l'essentiel encore
devant nous pourquoi parce que je
m'attends 1,2 d'augmentation des
faillites en particulier dans le tissu
des petites et moyennes entreprises
et derrière les fans y aura forcément
une augmentation du chômage
moi j'avais prévu à quelques semaines un
taux de chômage
disons house pour cent en mars va voir
mais ce qui est beau cul c'est
l'évolution du chômage en général et la
montée du chômage des jeunes
parce que cette crise accentue les
inégalités compris en cogénération la
question de l'accès des jeunes à quelque
chose parce qu il doit axer rien à peine
à l'université ça me paraît une question
centrale à bratton social permettraient
réellement d'empêcher cette situation un
bruno martin comment le gouvernement
peut doit intervenir selon vous deux
noirs donc oui enfin c'est à dire que la
mobilisation du printemps effectivement
mais elle est déjà en cours cette
mobilisation depuis le mois de décembre
on assisterait médiations successives de
différents secteurs et sur différents
thèmes un différents secteurs
professionnels bien sûr ce sera
différent de thématiques donc notamment
le les salariés du spectacle qui sonne
intermittent ou pas ont commencé à se
mobiliser dès le mois de décembre
on a également dans le secteur du
tourisme les salariés de tes nuits en
cellule anciennement nouvelles
frontières le secteur du tourisme est
vraiment sinistrés et qui en a d'autres
secteurs pour le sommeil est mobilisé
des hôpitaux les enseignements la ratp
en secteurs publics et privés ou publics
se mobilisent
mais en même temps son père malaise de
500 questions des libertés
et puis vous savez là pour l'om est cela
la santé est un état de bien-être total
physiques psychologiques et sociales et
c'est très difficile de concilier les
croire notamment en ce moment lorsqu'on
va améliorer les choses
d'un point de vue sanitaire avec une
discipline sanitaire assez dur ça va
moins bien au niveau social niveau
mental ou que les choix sont difficiles
à prendre mais en tout cas nous on va
pas laisser les choses sans rien faire
on souhaite vraiment mobilisés et dès le
4 février jeudi prochain il y aura une
journée un peu partout en france de
grèves et de manifestations pour faire
entendre les revendications
alors on reviendra sur cette journée de
mobilisation attendue mais qu'est ce que
c'est aussi votre grande vigilance
aujourd'hui c'est l'attitude des grands
groupes qu'est ce que vous craignez
précisément les grands groupes
certains prennent comme prétexte la
pandémie pour accélérer des plus grosses
opérations étaient déjà dans les tiroirs
donc on attend de nous des grands
groupes ainsi d'y maintenir l'emploi
quitte à appuyer aimons les salariés en
chômage partiel
par ailleurs nous souhaitons que ce
chômage partiel soir il est à 100%
voilà parce qu'il est important de
maintenir ses moteurs importants qu'ils
à la consommation des ménages
mais vous savez quand on doit payer son
loyer à la fin du mois on va en rire pas
voir son propriétaire en disant je vais
le payer qu'à 80%
ça se passe pas comme ça dans la vie
réelle alors parmi ces grands groupes on
évoque renault airbus sanofi encore
bridgestone est ce qu'elle est ce que
ces grands groupes profitent de la crise
pour se restructurer
christian de boissieu je sais pas s'ils
profitent
dans certains cas ça peut être un
prétexte il est clair qu'il ya des
situations qui sont plus ou moins
compliquées il ya des secteurs qui sont
sinistrés à mon avis durablement
sinitrés les connaissent et d'aérien
s'il tourisme
ces hôtels restaurants c'est une partie
de l'automobile donc clairement cette
crise va laisser des traces culturelles
bien au delà de la pandémie qui n'est
elle-même n'est pas finie et donc alors
tendu l'économie de marché
si l'état a bien sud a bien sûr à voile
à jouer ben des entreprises privées
arbitre chacune à sa façon dont j'ai été
choqué par certains de dos car quand
j'ai vu par exemple le cas de le
pourrait pas être concret j'ai regardé
un peu le cadre danone et annoncé des
suppressions d'emplois alors que danone
a été une des premières entreprises en
france à prendre le nouveau statut
entreprises à mission ce qui me paraît
un peu contradictoire une entreprise
émission ça veut dire qu'elle va au delà
de la recherche de la rentabilité à
court terme et qu'elle s'intéresse à les
uns à l'environnement social etc
et donc j'ai pas bien compris la
communication et même au delà de la
communication grâce à l'action de
groupes comme danone
donc il ya vraiment des des
comportements extrêmement hétérogène
certains à mon avis d'evian face à cette
crise alors qu'il faudrait certainement
un peu plus de solidarité
est-ce qu'il faudra aussi que les
différentes aides de l'état soient liés
à des conditionnalités en termes
d'emploi jeudi un mollet monsieur martin
ajoutera au contrat dira ce que je vais
dire mais moi je pense qu'il ya des cas
dans lesquels bien sûr les aides doivent
être conditionnés un certain nombre
d'actions alors il ya des êtres général
par exemple les prêts garantis pour
l'étaler pge là pour lesquels on vient
de donner un an plus pour le le le
remboursement
il n'y a pas de conditionnalité sur le
chômage partiel
il ya eu certains abus qui ont été
dénoncées mais peut-être pas tous parce
que dans certains cas y ait des effets
d'aubaine derrière le chômage partiel
mais je répète quand il s'agit de
mesures générales
c'est très difficile de poser des
conditions quand il s'agit d' aide un
peu spécifique à des secteurs voire à
des entreprises en particulier
là il me semble que c'est important de
poser des conditionnalités benoît martin
c'est votre ressenti aussi ce qu est ce
qu il ya une surveillance aujourd'hui de
la part de l'état quant aux aides
qu'elle accorde aux entreprises est bien
trop parmi les salariés et les
fonctionnaires qui sont syndiqués à la
cgt on a des camarades donc à travailler
aux finances publiques qui nous dise
quelle facilité des chèques sont fait
effectivement pas d'aidé d'entreprise
voilà donc nous on voit bien que pendant
qu'il ya des cas tout à fait
emblématique comme sanofi sanofi
bénéficie le dez le public sanofi des
vocalises sanofi suppriment des emplois
notamment dans la recherche sanofi le
verse des dividendes à ses actionnaires
et sanofi n'est pas capable de trouver
ni un antiviral ni un vaccin
d'ailleurs nous on pense qu'il ya du
travail pour les séries de sanofi dans
les mois qui viennent peut-être en
produisant un vaccin conçu par d'autres
entreprises puisque voilà il faudrait
que des choses soient un petit peu
facilité un os que les vaccins découvert
inventé récemment de passer dans le bien
commun et donc qu'on puisse s'affranchir
des histoires de propriété
intellectuelle et que l'on puisse là il
ya vraiment une urgence il ya une course
contre la montre
là il faut produire des vaccins et donc
la partie mouvement n'a été on a des
capacités de production même si on a
soi-même découvert le daxas on doit
pouvoir le produire et puisque je vis
aussi sur les aides publiques car là où
il ya eu des abus
non seulement les chevaux empêcher que
ça recommence mais les certaines
entreprises devraient rembourser les
aides publiques versées à tort et c'est
ce que nous dirons la semaine prochaine
pendant les jours qui viennent mais là
la semaine d'après nous aurons des
conférences sur l'emploi paris avec la
direccte avec l'amérique paris avec
d'autres idées sont syndicales et
patronales et donc nous ferons part de
nos propositions effectivement sur la
conditionnalité inde et des aides
publiques aux entreprises et parmi les
autres propositions de la cgt aussi
rendre impossible et les licenciements
dans le contexte actuel même s'il s'agit
de plan de départs volontaires alors les
licenciements départs volontaires n'est
pas un licenciement c'est peut être un
licenciement cacher il y a cinq ou six
façons maintenant nous faire partir les
gens dans les entreprises voilà en
donnant du pse habituelles voilà donc je
savais c'est une bombe à retardement
mettre les gens à la porte et c'est si
vous perdez solution d'attenté les gens
ne peuvent pas travailler avoir du
chômage partiel c'est quand même pas
plus mal et donc on nous pourrions enfin
dans un camp dit rana période
exceptionnelle mesure exceptionnelle ça
pourrait être le temps en ce moment
pourquoi pas de rétablir l'autorisation
administrative ou des licenciements pour
limiter l'ampleur du phénomène récent
boissieu ça vous semble réaliste
d'envisager d'interdire les
licenciements au moins pour cette
période
je me souviens du débat qu'on avait à
l'époque sur l'autorisation
administrative de licenciement
je pense qu'il faut trouver un équilibre
parce que si on bloque de manière
administrative des sentiments on va pas
faciliter les embauches et donc la
question de l'embauché est une question
essentielle parlais tout à l'heure des
jeunes femmes et étudiants aujourd'hui
ils ont du mal même à trouver un stage
quand je parle pas de d'accès à des cdd
les voir a fortiori à des des cdi dont
ils vont trouver il faut trouver
l'équilibré entre les contraintes
d'isoler les conditions du licenciement
est important
signée telle embauche les mesures qui
ont été prises à l'automne en septembre
pour faciliter le moule des jeunes pour
faciliter l'apprentissage d'alternance
tout ça m'a paru nécessaire mais
vraiment pas suffisant benoît martin
râteau dernier mot la cgt appelle donc à
la main ou à la mobilisation le 4
février prochain
en cette période de restrictions
sanitaires comment est ce qu'on fait
pour mobiliser les troupes
comment est-ce que l'action à syndical
serait en vente
bon les manifestations de rue il
continue de ta part dieu heureusement
voilà on appelle les manifestants tant
qu'organisateur les gestes barrières
notamment le port du masque on n'est pas
plus tassé dans une manifestation de la
cgtp dans le rer b où j'étais par
exemple encore vendredi dernier nous
étions à peu près six personnes au mètre
carré
mais regardez donc on est plutôt moins
tasser dans les manifestations
syndicales
mais le flot de questions c'est
également comment on maintient un lien
avec les travailleurs les travailleuses
et et des syndiqués eh bien ça se fait
beaucoup par l'utilisation de
visioconférence heureux évidemment et
puis voilà nous il ya moins de tracts de
messages électroniques sont dépendants
des dans le réseau militant et avec les
syndiqués donc on continue à changer
syndicalisme beaucoup de réunions avec
des les employeurs ou des cso la
première réunion d'instances
représentatives du personnel ont eu
également en distance yale donc voilà on
s'est adapté il est il est vrai que pour
nous le qu'en dira les rapports de force
syndicaux secret sur les lieux de
travail et un dans une période où le
télétravail s'est largement développée
donc c'est compliqué merci beaucoup
messieurs malheureusement le temps nous
manque on aura l'occasion de reprendre
ce débat christian boissieu vice
président du cercle des économistes à
benoît martin secrétaire général cgt
paris merci d'avoir pris tant de de
participer avec nous à ce débat ce soir
sur arte france